it's beginning to look a lot like
christmas in the mount charleston area
and today lee canyon open to skiers and
snowboarders we do have live team
coverage
sally jaramillo is standing by in the
weather center as the mountains could
get more snow next week but first let's
head out to madison kimbrough who spent
the day at lee canyon madison what a fun
assignment for you
yeah it really was so much fun and a lot
of people were up there for the first
time now all the runs will be open this
weekend
if you're planning to hit the slopes
this weekend it will look a lot
different than last year as there were
limitations in place this season
everything is open from the ski school
to the restaurant to the gift shop
they're also hiring whether that be for
front of house servers in their
restaurants to even ski instructors the
momentum is high for this season and
here's what some snowboarders had to say
about the day i'm definitely happy to be
out here with with friends and family
and everybody and just
everybody around
better than being locked down better
than than not being able to come out at
all well i got up at 6 a.m to make sure
we'd be here early and we're here about
a quarter to nine so we're here right
when it opens it was nice we got our
passes and everything is good as long as
there's snow and cold conditions
operators hope for the ski resort to be
open through march
now take a look as you can see snow on
the mountain three months ago the mount
charleston lodge was destroyed in a fire
you might remember that but you can
still come to lee canyon to eat and
enjoy hot cocoa too it's really open for
everyone skiers and snowboarders alike
reporting near mount charleston madison
kimbrough live local now